This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. We are back. Happy 2022. 2021 was a weird year full of unexpected twists and turns, but one thing you can count on as we turn the page to a new calendar year are the 99 PI mini stories. This week we have stories about monster dorms, suspicious activity in the tunnels under DC, the most beautiful and expensive pop record of all time, and jazz cups. Stay with us. Yeah, same to you, same to you. Is it your back again with another story? I am. Yeah. So today I want to share the story of someone who, I guess he just seems like a
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我们回来了。2022年新年快乐。2021年是个奇怪的一年，充满了意想不到的波折，但当我们翻开新日历时，有一件事是你可以指望的，那就是 99 PI 的迷你故事。本周我们有关于怪兽宿舍、华盛顿特区地下隧道的诡异活动、史上最美最贵的流行唱片，以及爵士纸杯的故事。请继续收听。是的，彼此彼此，彼此彼此。埃利奥特，你又带了一个新故事回来吗？是的。所以今天我想分享一个人的故事，我猜他看起来就像一个
quintessential beautiful nerd. He was born and raised in DC. He loves the city. He loves the obscure infrastructure of the city. He just feels like he fits on our show. But that's not the only reason I wanted to introduce our listeners to him. He also intersects with recent history in this very strange and kind of unsettling way. Okay. Well, I'm intrigued. Tell me more. So this guy's name is Elliot Carter. And when he was in his 20s, he did a Capitol Hill internship.
典型的美貌书呆子。他在华盛顿特区出生并长大。他热爱这座城市。他热爱这座城市鲜为人知的基建设施。他给人的感觉就是非常适合我们的节目。但这并不是我想向听众介绍他的唯一原因。他还以一种非常奇怪且有点让人不安的方式与近代史产生了交集。好吧。我很感兴趣。多讲一点。所以这个人叫埃利奥特·卡特。当他二十多岁的时候，他在国会山做过实习生。
And he said that this internship was quite boring, but that it did come with a perk, which is that they gave him an ID badge that allowed him to wander around the Capitol campus. And I spent this entire summer after college, basically, hungry for work from this office that wouldn't give me any, and just filling my time by, you know, disappear for two or three hours at a time when it was slow and just explore the building and kind of the campus really. And he gets really interested in the history of the Capitol complex, like the physical place.
他说这次实习相当无聊，但确实有一个好处，那就是他们给了他一个身份证徽章，允许他在国会园区闲逛。大学毕业后的整个夏天，我基本上都在渴望那个不肯给我任何工作的办公室能派点活儿，只是靠着在闲暇时消失两三个小时来打发时间，去探索这座建筑以及整个园区。他开始对国会大楼群的历史产生浓厚的兴趣，比如这个实体场所。
And especially the tunnels that run underneath it. Oh, I've heard a little bit about these tunnels, but I can't really picture them and I don't know what they're like, but I've heard about them. I would totally be in the same boat with Elliot. Yeah. Yeah. There's all different kinds of tunnels under the Capitol. They served different purposes. And Elliot got really intrigued. He started researching the history of them. And he learned that the tunnels started being built back in the Civil War era. So some of them were used to move books at high speed between the Library of Congress and the Capitol. I know, I know, I love that.
尤其是位于其下方的隧道。哦，我听说过一点关于这些隧道的风声，但我真的想象不出它们是什么样的，也不知道它们是怎样的，不过我确实听说过。我绝对会和埃利奥特处在同一阵线上。是的。国会下面有各种各样的隧道。它们有不同的用途。埃利奥特对此非常感兴趣。他开始研究它们历史。他了解到这些隧道早在内战时期就开始修建了。因此，其中一些隧道曾被用来在国会图书馆和国会大厦之间高速运送书籍。我知道，我知道，我太喜欢这个了。
And some of them house these huge underground air ducts that used to be packed with ice. It was like this early attempt at air conditioning. Wow. But the ones that really intrigue the public are these subways that are for congressmen and their staff members and visitors. And those really started to sprout on Capitol Hill right at the turn of the century. So the early 1900s. And those tunnels existed to shuttle congress people back and forth from the surrounding office buildings, which were going up around this time, to the actual capital building where they would cast their vote.
其中一些隧道里藏着巨大的地下通风管道，过去里面塞满了冰。这就像是早期对空调的尝试。哇。但真正引起公众兴趣的是供国会议员、其工作人员和访客使用的地铁。这些地铁正是在世纪之交时开始在国会山上涌现的。也就是20世纪初。这些隧道的存在是为了将国会议员在他们周围的办公楼（这些办公楼大约在这个时候兴建）与他们进行投票的实际国会大厦之间来回穿梭。
So they had to be able to get there fast, like within 15 minutes when a quorum was called. Oh, so these tunnels weren't about security as I was kind of picturing them. They're more about moving people back and forth quickly, so let a congressperson can jump on a subway and get to the capital in under 15 minutes. Yes, yes, exactly. But the public was also really curious about them and kind of suspicious of them, honestly, because they immediately thought it was about the secrecy. So, imagining an unpopular congressman who's getting berated by his constituents or by pesky reporters who were looking for quotes and imagining these people evading their tormentors by
因此他们必须能够快速到达那里，比如在召集法定人数的15分钟内。哦，所以这些隧道并不像我所想象的那样是为了安全。它们更多的是为了让人们能够快速来回穿梭，这样国会议员就可以跳上地铁，在15分钟内到达国会大厦。是的，是的，完全正确。但公众对它们也感到非常好奇，老实说甚至有点怀疑，因为他们立刻认为这与保密有关。因此，想象一下一个不受欢迎的国会议员，他正在遭到选民或正在寻找引语的讨厌记者的斥责，并想象这些人通过躲避他们的折磨者而
shuddling across the street and disappearing. That was very much on people's minds, but on the public side. Yeah, I can totally see that. They really tunnels lead to conspiracy theories. Like, yes, they certainly do and we are going to get into that more shortly. So, so there's a lot of interesting history behind the tunnels. Elliot got really into it. He started pulling together all this research, not just on the capital tunnels, but on all the tunnels that run under the city. And he put together this really lovely resource. It's a website called WashingtonTunnels.com. And it's full of beautiful maps of these different tunnel systems. As you might expect, it became popular among local history buffs and the DC architecture community,
匆忙穿过街道并消失。这在人们脑海中非常深刻，但就公众而言。是的，我完全可以理解这一点。隧道确实会引发阴谋乐论。就像，是的，它们当然会，我们稍后会对此进行更深入的探讨。所以，隧道背后有很多有趣的历史。埃利奥特对此非常着迷。他开始搜集所有这些研究，不仅关于国会隧道，还关于这座城市底下的所有隧道。他整理出了这个非常棒的资源。这是一个名为 WashingtonTunnels.com 的网站。里面装满了这些不同隧道系统的精美地图。正如你所料，它在当地历史爱好者和华盛顿特区的建筑界变得很受欢迎，
like those are his people. But here's where the story takes a turn, because about a year ago, in early 2021, on New Year's Day, Elliot started noticing some very weird traffic on his site, like not his usual visitors. I noticed like there was a unusually high volume of people who were kind of anonymizing themselves and they were from far away locations or using kind of anonymous browsers and search engines. And then a group of these people were being referred to my little friendly nerdy website from domains with names like AR15.com and mymolyshah.com. And these are not my normal friends in the Washington total community, so that kind of immediately raised a red flag.
就像那些是他的圈子一样。但故事在这里发生了转折，因为大约在一年前，即2021年初的元旦，埃利奥特开始在他的网站上注意到一些非常奇怪的流量，这不像是他平常的访客。我注意到，有异常大量的人隐藏了自己的身份，他们来自遥远的地方，或者使用某种匿名的浏览器和搜索引擎。然后，这些人的一个群体被从域名如 AR15.com 和 mymolyshah.com 引导到我的这个友好、书呆子气的小网站。这些不是我在华盛顿隧道社区的正常朋友，所以这立即引起了警惕。
Whoa. Okay, so what was going on? Well, Elliot started following some of the links back to see what was going on on these referring websites. So I clicked through these links and I'm looking at comment threads where someone will have screen-shotted my website and then they've annotated it, you know, with like the iPhone markup or the Snapchat markup with these arrows and texts saying, Patriots form here, block this entrance, look for escapes here, annotated like a Civil War battle plan with arrows and unit positions and stuff. Yeah, so he can actually immediately see what's happening.
哇。好吧，那到底发生了什么？嗯，埃利奥特开始追溯一些链接，看看这些引荐网站上到底在发生什么。所以我点击了这些链接，我看到了一些评论串，有人截了我的网站的图，然后他们做了标注，你知道，就像用苹果手机的标记功能或Snapchat的标记功能加上箭头和文字，写着“爱国者在此集结，封锁这个入口，在这里寻找逃生路线”，像内战作战计划那样标上了箭头和部队阵地之类的内容。是的，所以他实际上能立即看出发生了什么。
This was people who were planning the January 6th insurrection, and they were using his maps to talk about how they were going to surround and infiltrate the Capitol. Oh, my goodness. So what did Elliot then do with that information? He was disturbed enough that he sent a tip to the FBI's Washington Field Office. And he never heard anything back. And then a few days passed and it was January 6th. And we fight. We fight like hell.
这些是正在策划1月6日暴动的人，他们正在使用他的地图来讨论他们将如何包围和渗透国会大厦。哦，天哪。那么埃利奥特后来怎么处理这些信息呢？他感到十分不安，于是向联邦调查局（FBI）华盛顿现场办公室发送了一条线索。但他从未得到任何回复。然后几天过去了，就到了1月6日。我们要战斗。我们要拼死战斗。
And if you don't fight like hell, you're not going to have a country anymore. Are exciting adventures and boldest endeavors. And so that day, just as a quick recap, there was a rally near the White House. Trump spoke at it and repeated his lies about election fraud. And then thousands of attendees walked over to the Capitol building and hundreds of people actually broke in and went inside where Congress was beginning the electoral vote count. You know, it was terrifying.
如果你不拼死战斗，你将不再拥有一个国家。是激动人心的冒险和最大胆的尝试。所以在那天，作为一个简单的回顾，白宫附近举行了一场集会。特朗普在集会上发表了讲话，重复了他关于选举舞的谎言。然后成千上万的与会者走向国会大厦，数百人实际上闯入并进入了国会开始清点选举人票的内部。你知道，那太可怕了。
I mean, we all watched it happen. Yeah, absolutely terrifying. And Elliott says that everyone in DC that day knew that it was going to be chaotic. They'd basically been warned by the mayor to stay home if at all possible. And Elliott was up on the rooftop sunroom of his apartment building doing a Zoom call for work. Kind of watching this insurrection out the window, a couple blocks away, and then opening up like Google Analytics, and seeing in horror that there are like 600 people actively on this website right now. This is a quiet sleepy website. So like if you see 600 people in there,
我的意思是，我们都眼睁睁看着它发生。是的，绝对太可怕了。埃利奥特说，那天华盛顿特区的所有人都知道将会发生混乱。市长基本上已经警告过他们，如果可能的话尽量待在家里。而埃利奥特正站在他公寓楼屋顶的阳光房里开着工作Zoom会议。一边透过窗户看着这场几个街区外的暴动，一边打开谷歌分析，惊恐地发现此刻竟然有大约600人同时在线访问这个网站。这是一个安静冷清的网站。所以如果你看到上面有600人，
like there's something wrong. Wow, that sounds very unsettling but that he was somehow part of this thing that he completely objected to. That's terrifying. Yeah, yeah. I mean, regardless of his intentions when he built the site,
那就说明出问题了。哇，听起来真的很让人不安，但他却不知不觉地卷入了这件他强烈反对的事情中。这太可怕了。是的，是的。我的意思是，不管他建站时的初衷是什么，
he said he felt just afraid that he would be perceived as complicit. Yeah, I mean, he did report it. I mean, so clearly that wasn't his intention. But like, so what happened after January 6th? Well, so Elliott watched all the news coverage that unfolded after the attack and was kind of stunned by it. Like, the fact that the organizers were sharing tunnel maps was one of the things that the press and law enforcement
他说他只是感到害怕，担心自己会被视为同谋。是的，我的意思是，他确实举报了。所以很显然那不是他的本意。但是，那么1月6日之后发生了什么？嗯，埃利奥特观看了袭击发生后的所有新闻报道，并对此感到震惊。比如，组织者分享隧道地图的事实，成为了媒体和执法部门
were holding up as evidence of the advanced planning in this attack. Anytime they were talking about the capital tunnel maps that these people were sharing, they were talking about this obscure project that I had labored on. And so Elliot ended up pulling down the site for a time, just so he could have time to look back through it, line by line, and think about the information he'd shared.
用来作为这次袭击有预谋的证据之一。每当他们谈到这些人分享的国会隧道地图时，他们谈论的都是这个我曾苦心孤诣完成的冷门项目。因此，埃利奥特最终暂时关闭了该网站，好让他有时间逐行回顾，并思考他所分享的信息。
And if any of it should be changed, and he ultimately concluded, no, he felt he'd presented the information responsibly. It had all been stuff in the public domain. And so he put the site back up. And so did anyone ever follow up with him, like from the FBI or anything like that about the maps? He was never contacted by the FBI, but eventually the Senate Rules Committee published their first investigator report into the attack. And it had a couple of footnotes that referenced the tip that Elliott had submitted before the insurrection happened. Then after that, he was
以及其中的任何部分是否应该修改，他最终得出的结论是，没有，他觉得自己以负责任的态度呈现了这些信息。这些全部都是公共领域内的东西。于是他又把网站重新上线了。那么，有没有人联系过他，比如联邦调查局或者诸如此类的人，询问关于地图的事？他从未被联邦调查局联系过，但最终参议院规则委员会发布了他们的第一份关于此次袭击的调查报告。其中有几个脚注提到了埃利奥特在暴动发生前提交的线索。在那之后，他
contacted by the House Committee investigating January 6th, and actually had a conversation with them about the tip that he made. So they're trying to suss if law enforcement groups, like the FBI, drop the ball at all in their response to January 6th. Wow. So where does that leave Elliot today? I mean, you mentioned that the website was back up. Is it still up right now? It is.
被调查1月6日事件的众议院委员会联系了，并且实际上与他们就他提供的线索进行了对话。所以他们试图弄清楚执法机构（比如联邦调查局）在对1月6日事件的反应中是否存在失职。哇。那么这让埃利奥特现在处于什么位置？我的意思是，你提到网站已经重新上线了。它现在还在吗？还在。
Yeah, it's still up. It's a beautiful site. You should go look at it. And I think Elliot feels more strongly than ever that there's kind of a public service element to his site. He wants people to know about these tunnels about their real history. And this actually gets back to the conspiracy theory point
是的，它还在。这是一个很棒的网站。你应该去看看。而且我认为埃利奥特比以往任何时候都更加坚信，他的网站带有一种公共服务的元素。他希望人们了解这些隧道以及它们的真实历史。这其实又回到了阴谋论的那个观点
you made earlier. And he says that for as long as they have been around, the tunnels have been a subject of conspiracy and speculation and mistrust. Like, he gave this example of back in the 1930s. There were these wild ideas about how people were getting raped and mugged in the DC tunnels. And then more recently, like today, there are a source of fascination for QAnon believers who think that democratic politicians are involved in all sorts of completely fabricated stuff related to sex trafficking
你之前提到过。他说，自这些隧道存在以来，它们一直是阴谋、猜测和不信任的主题。比如，他举了这样一个例子：早在20世纪30年代。当时有一些离奇的想法，认为人们在华盛顿特区的隧道里遭到强奸和抢劫。而到了更晚的时候，就像今天一样，它们成了QAnon信奉者的着迷对象，这些人认为民主党政客参与了与性贩运
and kids. And they think the tunnels are part of that plot. So it sounds like Elliott in keeping Washington tunnels calm up and keeping it full of, you know, relatively mundane information about how these tunnels work is trying to just combat the lunacy that people associate with these tunnels. Yeah, he just wants people to know the true history of the tunnels, you know, in all their mundane glory. You know, if they're conspiracy people who are going to visit this website, I want them
和儿童有关的各种完全凭空捏造的事情。他们认为隧道是那个阴谋的一部分。所以听起来埃利奥特通过让 Washington tunnels.com 保持上线，并让它充斥着（你知道的）关于这些隧道如何运作的相对平淡的信息，是在试图打击人们与这些隧道联系起来的疯狂想法。是的，他只是想让人们了解隧道的真实历史，你知道的，带着它们所有平淡无奇的光辉。你知道，如果有一些阴谋论者要访问这个网站，我希望他们
to leave with the most idiot proof unambiguous takeaway of, this isn't secret. This is not nefarious. This is not a sex trafficking tunnel. Like, this is both more boring and more interesting and more complex than I had given a credit for. I've appointed myself as the spokesman of these tools now. Mm-hmm. I don't know if you can ever make it idiot proof, but I appreciate his effort. I know.
带着最傻瓜式、最明确无误的结论离开：这不是秘密。这不是邪恶的。这不是性贩运隧道。这既比我原本给它的评价更无聊，但也更有趣、更复杂。我现在自封为这些隧道的发言人了。嗯嗯。我不知道你是否真的能把它做到绝对傻瓜式，但我很欣赏他的努力。我知道。
Well, that's a fascinating story. Thank you so much for bringing it to us. Yeah, thank you. If you follow architecture news or just use social media at all, you may be familiar with Munger Hall, a proposed building for the University of California in Santa Barbara. The project is being sponsored in part by billionaire Charlie Munger of Berkshire Hathaway. The exterior design is not exactly ugly, it's plain and boxy, it's nothing right home about, but also nothing to get worked up over.
好吧，这是一个引人入胜的故事。非常感谢你带给我们这个。不客气，谢谢你。如果你关注建筑新闻或者哪怕只是使用社交媒体，你可能对芒格大厅（Munger Hall）有所耳闻，这是为加州大学圣巴巴拉分校提议建造的一栋建筑。该项目部分由伯克希尔·哈撒韦公司的亿万富翁查理·芒格赞助。其外观设计谈不上难看，只是朴素且方正，没有什么值得夸耀的，但也无需小题大做。
It was the unusual and cramped interior layout that led to headlines like all hail dorm zilla, the monster dorm, the internet hates. Our own Kurt Coles said, came across an unexpected angle to this story and is here to tell us more about what he found. Yeah, and what I found was pretty cool. There wasn't much press about this project until somebody leaked this letter that really ripped into it. And as it turns out, the leaker of that letter, the guy whose intervention sparked this whole cascade of like viral media coverage, is a 9% and visible fan. Oh yeah. And I found that out when he posted a comment about it in our 9% API subreddit. So I went ahead
正是这种不寻常且狭窄的内部布局引发了诸如“迎向宿舍zilla：互联网讨厌的怪兽宿舍”这样的头条新闻。我们自己的库尔特·科尔斯说，他偶然发现了这个故事的一个意想不到的角度，并在这里向我们详细讲述他所发现的内容。是的，我发现的内容非常酷。在有人泄露了一封猛烈抨击该项目的信件之前，关于这个项目的媒体报道并不多。事实证明，那封信的泄露者（那个其介入引发了这一系列病毒式媒体报道的人）是 9% Invisible 的粉丝。哦，真的是这样。当他在我们的 9% API 子版块（subreddit）评论时，我发现了这一点。所以我决定
and reached out to him and I asked if he'd be willing to talk to me about it in more detail. Yeah. Hi, I'm Mark Fuchsavitch. I'm an alumni of UCC and Barbara. I just graduated in June in political science, and I'm a former member of the Design Review Committee. And Mark has a lot to say about this project, starting with some of the big common criticisms. It is a large square structure that is 11 stories tall that will be holding 4,537 students and incredibly high density. Each of these rooms that these students are going to be single-occupancy rooms with no natural light and no fresh air ventilation. Well, there are some in the common areas, but yeah, for individual students, not so much.
联系他，并询问他是否愿意跟我更详细地聊聊这件事。你好，我是马克·福查维奇（Mark Fuchsavitch）。我是加州大学圣巴巴拉分校（UCC and Barbara）的校友。我刚刚在六月毕业，主修政治学，我曾是设计审查委员会的成员。马克对这个项目有很多话要说，首先是从一些重大的常见批评开始。这是一个大型的方形建筑，有11层楼高，将容纳4537名学生，人口密度极其之高。这些学生将要入住的每个房间都是单人间，没有自然光，也没有新鲜空气通风。好吧，公共区域有一些，但是是的，对于单个学生来说，就没那么多了。
Only 6% of the rooms actually face the exterior and have any sort of real windows. The rooms are something along the lines of 6 feet by 10 feet. Maybe it's a little larger, but really small, like prison cell size rooms. I mean, all of that sounds really depressing. When you compare a dorm room to a prison, that does not seem like a very great environment to live in. Yes, and that comparison to prisons is something that a lot of the news media picked up on. And Mark, you know, as a person who's recently lived in dorm rooms, he worries about how these small rooms could impact student mental health. And meanwhile, you meanwhile, the internet at large has taken
实际上只有6%的房间朝外，并且拥有任何形式的真正的窗户。这些房间的大小大约是6英尺乘10英尺。也许稍微大一点，但真的很小，就像监狱牢房大小的房间。我的意思是，所有这些听起来都非常令人沮丧。当你把宿舍房间和监狱进行比较时，这似乎并不是一个非常适合居住的环境。是的，与监狱的这种比较是许多新闻媒体注意到的一个方面。而马克，你知道的，作为一个最近住过宿舍房间的人，他担心这些小房间会如何影响学生的心理健康。与此同时，你，与此同时，广大互联网开始
to calling this whole thing dorms alone, because it's really kind of a monster, right? In building. And so, it's being planned, I mean, it was vetted by a certain group of people. Why does anyone think that this dorm has a good idea? So the argument in favor, as I understand it, is that if you give people only a tiny amount
把这一切称为“宿舍zilla”，因为它确实有点像个怪兽，对吧？是一座建筑。所以，它正在被规划，我的意思是，它是由特定的一群人审查过的。为什么会有人觉得这个宿舍是个好主意呢？据我理解，支持的论点是，如果你只给人们提供少量的
of personal space, that will force them out into common areas. And from there, it will force them out onto campus. And so in the grand scheme of things, this would lead to more socialization, which would be good. But that all seems kind of speculative to me. And if anything, you could also imagine the opposite. Having a room to yourself makes it easier to just be by yourself. And folks like Mark and me for that matter worry about the lack of data and theory
个人空间，这就会迫使他们走到公共区域去。从那里开始，它将迫使他们走到校园里去。因此，从宏观角度来看，这会带来更多的社交活动，这会是件好事。但这在我看来似乎有点凭空猜测。如果非要说的话，你也可以想象出相反的情况。拥有属于自己的房间让人更容易独处。而像马克和我这样的人则担心缺乏数据和理论
that's really driving this approach to design. And so how did Mark find himself in the middle of this? You mentioned he was a student. why was he involved at all? Well, so there's one student representative at a time on the University's design review committee and So he sat alongside faculty and staff and other experts reviewing design proposals for the campus and Those could be anything from bike lanes and you know landscaping to empire buildings like this one. It's a pretty niche position that not a lot of people care about, but through listening to great podcasts,
来真正推动这种设计方法。那么马克是如何发现自己卷入其中的呢？你提到他是一名学生。他为什么会参与其中呢？嗯，所以大学的设计审查委员会里同时有一名学生代表，因此他和教职员工以及其他专家坐在一起审查校园的设计提案。这些可以是任何东西，从自行车道和景观美化到像这样的宏伟建筑。这是一个非常小众的职位，没有多少人关心，但通过听伟大的播客，
I've really come to care about design and urban planning. So is he talking about us there? Oh, yes, he's talking about us. He loves us. Oh, it's so nice to hear. OK, so Mark gets on this committee that no one else, no other student, no volunteers for. And nobody cares about it.
我真的开始关心设计和城市规划了。所以他在那里是在说我们吗？哦，是的，他在说我们。他爱我们。哦，听到这个真好。好的，所以马克进入了这个没有其他人、没有其他学生、没有志愿者争着要去的委员会。而且没有人关心它。
So except for Night and P.I. listeners, so that's a great thing that we're putting that out into the world. And so Mark's on this committee, and this project comes up for review while he's on the committee. Well, okay, technically no. I should clarify that he wasn't officially still a member at this point.
所以除了Night和P.I.的听众之外，所以我们把这个带给世界是一件很棒的事情。因此，马克在这个委员会里，而这个项目在他任职期间提交进行审查。好吧，技术上来说没有。我应该澄清，此时他已经不是官方的正式成员了。
He had just graduated, but he still got the meeting invites. And so he went to this meeting. And the meeting felt really different to him. He recalls the committee basically being told, your feedback isn't going to matter. It seemed to him that the monger hall review was more about rubber stamping the design. And after a slideshow, he recalls the organizer
他刚刚毕业，但他仍然收到了会议邀请。所以他去参加了这个会议。这次会议给他留下了非常不同的感觉。他回忆说，委员会基本上被告知：“你们的反馈并不重要。”在他看来，对芒格大厅的审查更像是对设计的橡皮图章式批准。在幻灯片演示之后，他回忆起组织者
saying something like, any feedback that you guys give will be taken as suggestions, and will likely may or may not be incorporated in design. You have this meeting is not to have any upper-down vote on this project. So, it's a radical departure of what previous procedures were and how a building gets designed and come about. And so, after this meeting, he sends an email to the whole Review Committee's member list,
说了一些类似这样的话：“你们给出的任何反馈都将被视为建议，很可能会或可能不会被纳入设计中。你们这次会议的目的不是对这个项目进行投赞成票或反对票。”因此，这与以前的程序以及建筑如何设计和产生的过程有着根本的偏离。所以，在这次会议之后，他向整个审查委员会的成员名单发送了一封电子邮件，
expressing his frustration about how the meeting went. And he wasn't the only one with strong opinions. This other member responded to the thread, explaining that he was actually quitting the committee entirely because of this project. When Dennis McFadden, the architect, sent his resignation letter, she sent it in reply to my email
表达了他对会议进展情况的沮丧。而且他并不是唯一一个有强烈意见的人。另一位成员回复了该邮件串，解释说实际上是因为这个项目他正准备彻底辞去委员会的职务。当建筑师丹尼斯·麦克法登（Dennis McFadden）发送他的辞职信时，她是回复了我发给整个委员会的电子邮件发送的。
that I sent the entire committee. And McFadden was this consulting architect on the committee, he'd been there for over a decade. But his resignation letter went into a lot of detail about issues he had with the building and the review process. And some of the stuff is pretty damning. Like, quote, the basic concept for mongerhal as a place for students to live is unsupportable
麦克法登是委员会的顾问建筑师，他在那里任职超过十年。但他的辞职信详细说明了他对这座建筑以及审查过程所存在的问题。其中有些内容相当具有毁灭性。比如，引述：“从我作为一名建筑师、一位家长和一个人的角度来看，将芒格大厅作为学生居住地的基本概念是站不住脚的。”引述结束。好的。没错。所以马克看到了这一点，他基本上赞同这些情绪，并决定将麦克法登的信发到网上，他完全不知道这会变成一个如此巨大的故事。我在UCSB的Reddit上发布了他的信，以为它会得到
from my perspective as an architect, a parent, and a human being. End quote. OK. Right. So Mark saw this and he basically agreed with the sentiments and decided to post McFadden's letter online and he had no idea this was gonna become this huge story. I posted his letter on the UCSB Reddit thinking it would get
一些校友的注意，也许能引起一些当地记者的注意，仅此而已。但当然，它的影响力远远超过了这一点。在事情病毒式传播之后，他对于没有事先征得麦克法登的同意感到有些后悔。我为此感到难过，我也确实为在发布丹尼斯的信件之前没有征得他的同意而感到难过，因为我确信这让他的手机和邮箱瘫痪了好几天。无论如何，一切都已经大白于天下了。马克同意批评者的观点，他们指出了缺乏自然光、缺乏空气流通的问题，但他同时也认为，对于其他一些重要问题的报道还不够，
attention of some alumni and maybe get the attention of some like local journalists, nothing more than that. But of course it went much bigger than that. And after it went viral, he had some regrets about not asking for Madden's permission first. I feel bad about that and I do feel bad about at least not asking for consent to Dennis before I leave his letter, because I'm sure it destroyed his phone in his email for a few days. In any case, it's all out in the open now. And Mark agrees with critics who have pointed out the lack of natural light, the lack of air circulation, but he also thinks that there hasn't been enough coverage about some other important issues,
比如这座建筑可能会如何影响学生的健康。不用说，总的来说，他对这个项目有着非常负面的感受。所以当得知他的立场在这个问题上并非完全是一边倒时，我实际上感到有些惊讶。那么他，他喜欢“宿舍zilla”的什么呢？嗯，与其说是喜欢建筑本身，不如说是喜欢有人试图解决校园里巨大的学生住房危机。为了把这种规模置于背景之中，整个加州大学系统今年秋天不得不将超过15,000名学生列入住房候补名单。哇。我真的很担心这可能会耽误4500个单位的建设，而该地区对这些单位有着严重的需求。4500个单位占了候补名单上15,000个中的很大一部分。
like how the building might impact student health. Needless to say, overall, he has this very negative feeling towards the project. So it was actually a bit of a surprise to me to learn that his position isn't entirely one-sided on it. So what is he, what is he like about dorms all of them? Well, it's not so much about liking the building itself, but it is about liking the fact that there's an attempt to address a huge student housing crisis on campus. And just to put the scale of this in context, the whole UC system had to put more than 15,000 students on a housing waiting list this past fall. Wow. It is really like a worry of mine that this might derail 4500 units, which are severely needed in the area. 4,500 units is a big chunk out of 15,000 on a waiting list.
确实很大一部分。所以你可以明白为什么这并不是一个非黑即白、只需说“让我们阻止这个项目”的简单案件。马克本人对这种住房紧缺有着非常深刻的个人体验。你知道，他认识被安置在危机住房中的学生，他也看到其他学生试图弄清楚如何有效地住在他们的车里。“嘿，如果我住在车里，我能用你的洗浴间吗？你知道的，我只为浴室和厨房付房租。”
It is. It really is. And so you can see why this is not exactly a clear cut case of just, you know, like, let's just stop this project. And Mark himself, he's got a lot of personal familiarity with this housing crunch. You know, he knows students who have been put in crisis housing, and he's seen other students trying to figure out how to effectively live out of their cars. Hey, if I live in my car, can I use your bathroom? You know, I'll pay rent for just the bathroom in the kitchen.
我的意思是，那种情况听起来太糟糕了。是的，确实如此。而且这在加州大学圣巴巴拉分校并非非正式的或偶然的事情。加州有一所大学实际上为找不到住房的学生设立了一个停车区。所以基本上鼓励他们把车开到那里并在校园里睡觉。哇。我的意思是，我猜这总比他们睡在不安全的地方要好，但这绝对不是长久之计。我的意思是，这太糟糕了。
I mean, that situation just sounds terrible. Yeah, it does. And it isn't just an informal or a one-off thing at UCSB. There's one California University that has actually put up a parking area for students who can't find housing. So they're basically encouraged to go and take their car and sleep there on campus. Wow. I mean, I guess that's better than them sleeping someplace that isn't to hear and might be more dangerous, but that is not a long-term solution. I mean, I guess that's better than them sleeping someplace that isn't to hear and might be more dangerous, but that is not a long-term solution. I mean, that's terrible.
是的，一点也不好。因此，鉴于所有这些住房问题，马克仍然讨厌这个设计，但他对由他协助引爆的这个故事的副作用感到担忧。我内心还有另一部分理解我们所处的住房危机。所以我现在能明白为什么他对这件事抱有矛盾的心理了。那么他对于这场更大的危机有什么看法呢？部分原因，他指责大学没有早点花钱建造住房，等待了这么久，让它演变成了一场危机。
Yeah, not at all. And so, in light of all of these housing issues, Mark still hates the design, but he has concerns about the side effects of this story that he helped break. There's another part of me that understands the housing prices that we're in. So I can see now why he is up to minds about this. So what's his take on this larger crisis? So in part, he blames the university for not spending up housing sooner, for waiting this long, for letting it become a crisis.
但他也指出了超级富豪在塑造学术机构中扮演的角色。在这个案例中，查理·芒格不仅是资助芒格大厅的最大单一捐赠者，而且他一直是其建筑设计背后的推动力。请记住，芒格是一位投资者，就像他的老板沃伦·巴菲特一样。
But he also points to the role that the ultra rich have in shaping academic institutions. In this case, not only is Charles Munger, the largest single donor, backing Munger Hall, but he's also been a driving force behind its architectural design. And remember, Munger is an investor, like his boss, more and buff it.
是的，我的意思是，在这种情况下，他似乎并不具备建筑专业知识。没错。所以这里的问题一部分在于，他只出了资助这栋建筑所需资金的一小部分，这确实让项目得以启动，在某种程度上这确实是好事。但不知何故，尽管只出了一部分资金，他却实际上获得了对该设计的主控权。很显然，这种影响力，
Yeah, I mean, it doesn't seem like he has an architectural expertise in that case. That's right. And so part of the issue here is that he put up this fraction of the amount needed to fund the building, which did get the project started, which on some level is good. But somehow, despite only putting up some of the money, he's getting essentially a controlling interest in the design. And obviously, this kind of influence,
业余建筑师设计建筑物，就像对我们的学术机构拥有这种级别的控制权一样，你可以看出这会产生一些问题。我们的高等教育机构现在基本上不仅受百万富翁和富人的指引。我们在谈论的是亿万富翁，基本上现在不仅仅由百万富翁和富人指引。我们在谈论的是像亿万富翁这样的人，
amateur sort of architects designing buildings, like having this kind of level of control over our academic institutions, you can see how that would create some problems. Our institutions of higher learning are essentially guided now by not just millionaires in Rich and Rich and Bull. We're talking about billionaires, like essentially guided now by not like just millionaires and rich people. We're talking about like billionaires,
那些拥有足够多的钱以至于可以扮演上帝的人。那，是的，这让我很担忧。马克认为我们所处的这个经济和政治时刻是这个故事像这样爆炸式传播的一个因素。你知道，很多人都关心财富不平等以及在美国谁通过金钱拥有权力。我真的认为这证明了亿万富翁在我们的社会中正在做的事情，以至于来自圣巴巴拉一个小地方的故事会传得如此广泛。我的意思是，我认为
people who have enough money that they can play God. That, yeah, it worries me. And Mark sees this economic and political moment were in as a factor in the story blowing up like it did. You know, a lot of people are concerned with wealth inequality and who has power via the money in America. I really think this is like a testament to what billionaires are doing in our society that the story from a little area of Santa Barbara would go this viral. I mean, I think
这就是为什么这个故事能引起人们如此大共鸣的原因，是查理·芒格的部分真正让它像其他任何事情一样广为流传。我理解你需要高密度的学生宿舍，并且这必须发生。很显然，这栋建筑并不是解决该问题的适当的整体方案。所以我不太确定这其中最重要的一部分是什么。任何对这个话题的利弊以及辩论感兴趣的人，我真的鼓励你们去读读麦克法登的信。它写得非常有力量。是的。好吧，谢谢你，库尔特。这是一个很棒的故事。我很高兴我们能对它有更多的了解。
that's why the story had so much resonance with people was that it was it was the Charlie Munger part of it that really made it viral as much as anything else. I understand that you need dense student housing and that needs to happen. It seems clear that this building is not the proper holistic solution to that problem. So like I'm not sure what is the most important part of this. Anybody who's sort of interested in the pros and cons and the debate over this, I'd really encourage you to read Big Fadden's letter. It's really powerfully written. Yeah. Yeah. Well, thank you, Kurt. It's a great story. I'm so glad we got a little bit more perspective into it.
我也很高兴有人能带着这种 99 PI 的精神去审视、深入审视这个人工建造的世界，然后意识到他们可以为此做些点什么。这真的，呃，这真的让我感到高兴，安特。是的。好吧，谢谢你，在节目的下一部分中。精明的听众可能还记得，这些年来我曾多次谈到他的乐队 Beauty Pill。我很喜欢他们。Beauty Pill 有一张名为 Instant Night 的全新 12 英寸单曲。它有四首歌，并且都作为数字下载在 Bandcamp 上提供。但这次发行的特别之处，也是查德和我有一天在电话里谈论它的原因之一，是因为他们决定为这些歌曲创作非常引人注目且美丽的黑胶唱片和 CD 包装。这是一张完全半透明的、基本上是隐形的（我给这个词加上引号）唱片。这是一个设计实验。它看起来不像其他的唱片。设计师诺拉·麦克尔维（Nora McKelvie）创作了一张透明的
And I'm so glad that somebody took this sort of 99 PI spirit to examine, deeply examine the built world and then realize that there was something they could do about it. And that's just, uh, that just pleases me to know, Ant. Yeah. Well, thank you, in the next video. of the show and Eagle Ear listeners may recall that I've talked about his band Beauty Pill a couple of times over the years. I love them. Beauty Pill has a new 12-in-single called Instant Night. It has four songs and they're all available as digital downloads on Bandcamp. But what is particularly notable about this release and one of the reasons Chad and I were talking about it on the phone one day was because they decided to create really striking and beautiful vinyl and CD packaging for the songs. It is an entirely translucent, basically invisible, I'm putting that in quotes record. It's a design experiment. It doesn't look like other records. The designer Nora McKelvie created a clear
黑胶唱片和一个带有银色锡箔排版的透明塑料封套。这是一件华丽的东西。在一个带有银箔排版的透明塑料封套里。这是一件华丽的东西。但 12 英寸单曲的经济学很复杂，特别是当它们被制作成精美的设计对象时。所以乐队往往不会发行很多这样的唱片。但我喜欢 12 英寸单曲的概念，因为我喜欢 New Order。
vinyl record and a clear plastic sleeve with silver foil typography. It is a gorgeous thing. in a clear plastic sleeve with silver foil typography. It is a gorgeous thing. But the economics of a 12 inch single are complicated, particularly when they're made to be beautiful design objects. So bands don't tend to release a lot of them. But I love the idea of a 12 inch single because I love New Order.
这就把我们带到了查德·克拉克关于史上最畅销 12 英寸单曲的迷你故事，传说中，由于其设计，这也是一场彻底的财务惨败。我说的是 New Order 的《Blue Monday》。对于不知道的人来说，是一首《Blue Monday》。其实，我要大胆地说一句，不管你觉得自己知不知道《Blue》，你其实都知道《Blue Monday》。你觉得这完全正确。
Which brings us to Chad Clark's mini story about the best selling 12 inch single of all time, which Legend Goes was also a complete financial fiasco because of its design. I'm talking about New Order's Blue Monday. A blue Monday for people who don't know it. Actually, I'm going to just be bold enough to say you do know Blue Monday whether or not you think you know Blue. You think that's exactly right.
你一定在某种程度上听过它。是的。就是那首歌，你去过舞会、去过学校舞会、去过夜店，你在某种程度上都听过它。老实说，如果你去过超市，你都听过这首歌。《Blue Monday》的 12 英寸单曲于 1983 年发行，封面由才华横溢的彼得·萨维尔（Peter Savall）设计。他将《Blue Monday》的封面设计得像一张软盘。年轻的人们可能不知道那是什么，但软盘实际上是那个时代开始存储数据的方式。
You've heard it in some way. Yes. It's the song that goes you've been in a dance, a school dance, you've been in a club, you've heard it in some way. Honestly, if you've been in the supermarket, you've heard the song. The 12 and single for Blue Monday came out in 1983 and the cover was designed by the brilliant Peter Savall. He designed the Blue Monday cover to resemble a floppy disk. People who are younger won't know what that is, but a floppy disk was the way the data was beginning to be stored actually at that time.
当他把软盘作为标志性图像时，在当时其实是处于前沿的。这是一件新鲜事，并且被认为非常具有未来感。故事是这样的，彼得·萨维尔当时正在录音室拜访 New Order，当时他们正开始尝试电子音乐。他在桌子上看到了一张 5 英寸的软盘，心想：这到底是个什么鬼东西？但这完全启发了他。
When he used the floppy disk as an iconic image, it was actually cutting edge at that time. It was a new thing, and it was considered very futuristic. The story goes that Peter Savill was visiting new order in the studio as they were just beginning to experiment with electronic music. And he saw a five inch floppy disk on the table and he was like, what the hell is this thing? But it totally inspired him.
我想他甚至都不明白那是什么。彼得所了解的是某种令人兴奋且看起来很奇怪的东西。软盘是正方形的，但它们有小切口。这实际上引出了《Blue Monday》传奇中一个非常重要的部分。彼得是一位非常严谨的设计师，他坚持 12 英寸封面的形状必须完全模仿软盘。软盘有所谓的模切孔，基本上，你可以通过它们看到暴露的数据。在这个案例中，在他的设计中，
I don't think he even understood what it was. Peter's new was something exciting and odd looking. Floppy disks are square, but they have little cutouts. And that actually brings to a really important part of the Blue Monday Fable. Peter is a very exacting designer, and he insisted that the form of the 12 inch had to mimic a floppy disk exactly. And floppy disks have what they call die cut poles in them, basically, where you can see the data exposed. In this case, in his design,
数据就是黑胶唱片，对不起，这简直是天才。我的意思是，花点时间真正地去认识它。但只需要花一点时间去想：他本质上是该设计的符号学之一，他是在说这段音乐里有数据。这对我来说既沉重又美丽，作为一个艺术家，这非常鼓舞人心。
the data being the vinyl record, which is, I'm sorry, that is just genius. I mean, take a moment to really know for real. But just take a moment to be like, he is essentially one of the semiotics of this design, is he's saying there is data in this music. And that's just that's just heavy and beautiful to me as an artist that's very inspiring.
但是，坚持模切是一个非常不寻常的切割。压制必须定制设计，而且生产成本昂贵。除了定制切割之外，它在边缘还有全彩带状设计，这增加了成本。它的生产成本如此之高，以至于唱片公司最终出售这张唱片时完全没有盈利。《Blue Monday》伴随着巨大的资金损失，在我看来，这也是其传奇浪漫色彩的一部分，这些人非常关切他们所做事情的设计的具体性，
But so and insisting on the die cut, it was a very unusual cut. The pressing had to be custom designed and it was expensive to produce. In addition to the custom cuts, it also has a full color banding on the edge, which added to the expense. It was so expensive to produce that the label ended up selling the record, not at a profit at all. There was a significant loss of money attached to Blue Monday, which is part of, to me, the romance of its fable, these people cared so much about being specific, about the design of what they're doing,
以至于他们忘记了底线。对我而言，作为一个艺术家，我只是觉得这非常鼓舞人心、非常酷、而且非常浪漫，我猜。但这并不是什么浪漫的姿态。这只是一次疏忽。据报道，每卖出一张《Blue Monday》，唱片公司就会亏损大约七美分。从我看到的他们谈论这件事的反应来看，他们似乎对发生的这个错误感到有点尴尬，或者可能有点害羞。我认为 Factory Records 是一家出了名混乱的商业运营公司，里面有很多毒品、放荡和各种疯狂的事情。
that they forgot the bottom line. And for me, again, as an artist, I just find that very inspiring and very cool and very romantic, I guess. But it wasn't meant to be a romantic gesture. It was just an oversight. And it's been reported that the label lost about seven cents each time a copy of Blue Monday was old. What I've seen of them talking about it, I think they feel a little embarrassed, or maybe a little bit sheepish about the mistake that happened. I think factory records was a notoriously chaotic business operation, and there was a lot of drugs and deboutry and all sorts of craziness.
我猜唱片公司最终调整了制造成本或价格来使一切平衡，但依然如此。即使在财务上受损也要发表声明，这其中有一种美感。所以当你听到这是史上最畅销的 12 英寸单曲这个统计数据时，这个统计数据带有一个星号，意思是它是有史以来最赔钱的唱片之一。仅以一个独立音乐人的身份来说，我做过很多艺术上和其他方面的选择，这些选择并没有让我发财。这其中真的有一种，
I presume that label adjusted the manufacturing cost or the price to get it all into balance eventually, but still. There's just something beautiful to making a statement even when it hurts financially. And so when you hear the statistic that this is the best-selling 12-inch of all time, that statistic has an asterisk to it, which is like it's one of the most money-losing records ever. And just speaking as an independent musician who has made a lot of choices, artistic and otherwise, that have not led me to getting rich. There's just something really just,
我不知道，就是有一种很美妙的感觉。这就是我的《Blue Monday》看法。让我进去吧，你们这群胆小鬼，让我进去，我发誓你们会喜欢我的。让我进去吧，你们这群胆小鬼，让我进去。你们不认识像我这样的人也许我可以成为你的朋友你能把我当作你的朋友吗？让我进去吧，你们这群胆小鬼，让我进去，你们不认识像我这样的人。你需要一个更好的头脑，亲爱的，我可以告诉你的人。你需要一个更好的头脑，亲爱的，没关系，我会教你的。你需要一个更好的头脑。柴可夫斯基是乐队 PewDiePie 的首席词曲作者。
I don't know, just something kind of beautiful about it. So that's my, um, Blue Monday take. Let me in your cowards let me in I swear you're gonna like me Let me in your cowards let me in You don't know nobody like me Maybe I could be your friend Could you see me as your friend? Let me in your cowards let me in, you don't know nobody like me. You need a better mind, honey, someone I can tell you. You need a better mind, honey, that's okay, I'll teach you. You need a better mind. Tchaikovsky is the chief songwriter of the band PewDiePie.
新的 12 英寸单曲名为 Instant Night。我真的很偏爱 B 面。它叫《You Need A Better My》。你的生活中缺少了什么是什么让它成为最艰难的时刻？现在的孤独以及你的内心也一直在了解它也许我们可以相处融洽告诉我这怎么可能是错的呢现在的孤独以及你的内心也一直在我的心中。
The new 12-inch single is called Instant Night. I'm really partial to the B side. It's called, You Need A Better My. Something is missing in your life What has it's been the hardest time? The loneliness now and at your heart has also been knowing about it Maybe we could get along Tell me how could that be wrong? The loneliness now and at your heart has it's all so been on in mine.
这张全新的12英寸单曲名为《Instant Night》。我个人非常偏爱B面。它叫《You Need A Better My》。你的生活中缺少了点什么，什么时候是最艰难的时刻？现在的孤独以及你心中的感受，其实也一直伴随着了解它的过程。也许我们可以相处融洽，告诉我这怎么会有错？现在的孤独以及你心中的感受，其实也一直存在于我的心中。
You need a better mind. I need someone I have to tell you. You need a better mind. I need a hot, so good, I do too. Coming up after the break, an indelible design featured on disposable cups. Stay with us. Okay, Christopher Johnson, what do you have for us?
你需要一个更好的头脑。我需要有人我必须告诉你。你需要一个更好的头脑。我也需要一个性感、非常好的。休息回来后，我们将为你介绍印在一次性纸杯上一个难以磨灭的设计。请继续收听。好的，克里斯托夫·约翰逊，你给我们带来了什么？
The late 80s Roman. How well do you remember the late 80s and the early 90s? I would say I remember them very well. That was like, that was prime Roman time with like kind of 13 to 17, you know, I like that prime Roman time. So do you remember how everything was like all bright and poppy and neon or damn near neon? Electric and busy with squiggles and squaggles and shapes and you saw it on on skater shoes and in music videos Company logos. I remember James shorts remember those Remember those from the Mood 80s?
80年代末的罗曼。你对80年代末和90年代初的记忆有多深刻？我会说我记得非常清楚。那就像是，那是罗曼的黄金时代，大概13到17岁左右，你知道的，我喜欢那个罗曼的黄金时代。所以你还记得当时一切看起来都那么明亮、充满流行感和霓虹色，或者说几乎就是霓虹色吗？充满电感和活力，到处都是涂鸦、弯曲的线条和各种形状，你在滑板鞋上、音乐录影带里以及公司标志上都能看到它。我还记得詹姆斯短裤，你还记得那些吗？还记得80年代末的那些吗？
Absolutely. Like, very bright shorts with lots of socks. Yeah, absolutely. And so nothing was safe, right? Everything had this aesthetic on it. And nothing says to me, late 80s or early 90s, more than this paper cup design, those called jazz. So I'm going to show it to you.
当然。就像那种色彩非常鲜艳、配有高筒袜的短裤。是的，绝对是。所以没有什么东西是安全的，对吧？每一样东西都有这种美学风格。没有什么比这款名为“爵士”的纸杯设计更能代表80年代末或90年代初了。所以我打算把它展示给你看。
And how, so take a look at this, how would you describe this jazz cup? Well, I know this cup very, very well. So it's, it is a broad, wide turquoise kind of zigzag stripe. And it's overlaid with a thinner purple zig-zag stripe. And it is just, it is just something else. But you really, it is like ubiquitous. These cups are everywhere. They're a staplet conferences and in break rooms all across America. So where does the jazz cup come from? So design geeks have been obsessed with figuring out that question. And they want to know who came up with the jazz cup for years. So, design geek has been obsessed with figuring out that question. And they want to know who came up with the jazz cup. For years, no one could figure out who designed it. It was this big
那么，请看这个，你会如何形容这个爵士纸杯呢？嗯，我非常非常了解这个杯子。所以它是一个宽阔的、绿松石色的之字形条纹，上面重叠着一条较细的紫色之字形条纹。它真的是，真的是独一无二。而且它真的是无处不在。这些杯子随处可见。它们是全美各地会议和茶水间的常客。那么这个爵士杯是从哪里来的呢？设计达人们多年来一直痴迷于弄清楚这个问题。他们想知道是谁发明了爵士杯，多年来，设计达人们一直痴迷于弄清楚这个问题。他们想知道是谁发明了爵士杯。多年来，没有人能搞清楚是谁设计了它。这是一个巨大的
mystery. And then in 2015, a reporter at the Springfield News Leader in Missouri tracked down the woman believed to be the creator of this iconic piece of disposable tableware art. My name is Geina Iqas. I'm the creator of the jazz cup design. Just recently became another sensation. Geina lives in Aurora, Missouri, and she's been doing art since she was a kid. As far back as I can remember, I've been drawing and painting and getting into trouble because of it, just things like that.
谜团。直到2015年，密苏里州《斯普林菲尔德新闻领袖报》的一名记者找到了被认为是这件标志性一次性餐具艺术品创造者的女性。我叫盖娜·伊基斯。我是爵士杯设计的创作者。最近它再次成为了一个轰动的话题。盖娜住在密苏里州的奥罗拉，她从小就开始画画。从我有记忆起，我就一直在画画、涂鸦，也因此惹了不少麻烦，诸如此类的事情。
My mom, when I was five, she painted the bathroom cabinetry white. And to me, that was an open invitation. So I drew pictures all over it and she was not very thrilled. So when my dad got home, he pulled me aside, he said, well, here's your options. I can either give you a spanking or I'm going to take your crayons away for a week. I said, I'll take the spanking. That's a woman who loves her art, a girl who loves her art, and a woman who loves her art.
我五岁时，我妈妈把浴室的橱柜漆成了白色。对当时的我和我来说，那简直是一个公开的邀请。所以我在上面到处画画，她可一点也不高兴。等我爸爸回家后，他把我拉到一边，他说，好吧，你现在有两个选择。要么我屁股上狠狠揍你一顿，要么我把你的蜡笔没收一个星期。我说，我选挨揍。这是一个热爱艺术的女人，一个热爱艺术的女孩，也是一个热爱艺术的女人。
And she stuck with it. In the late 80s, she graduated from college with an art degree, and she landed her first job at Sweetheart Cup Company in Springfield, Missouri. And she became what was called a general line artist. That's someone who designs their cups and bowls and plates and stuff like that. And they had clients that include a Taco Bell, McDonald's and even little mom and pop stores.
她坚持了下来。80年代末，她从大学美术专业毕业，并在密苏里州斯普林菲尔德的甜心杯业公司找到了她的第一份工作。她成了一名所谓的综合产品线美术设计师。也就是专门设计杯子、碗和盘子之类东西的人。他们的客户包括塔可钟、麦当劳，甚至还有当地的小夫妻杂货店。
The company was doing really well, but there was one area where it was struggling a bit. See, like sweetheart also put its own designs on paper products. And those designs weren't very interesting. And in the late 80s, Ika says that the company decided that it was time for a new look on its own products, which makes sense.
公司的业务蒸蒸日上，但有一个领域却有点吃力。你看，甜心公司也会在纸制品上印上自己的设计。而那些 designs 并不是很有趣。伊基斯说，在80年代末，公司决定是时候为其自身的产品赋予一种全新外观了，这很合情理。
It's about to be a new decade. Let's kick in the door. The 90s with something that's fresh, or the picnics and the office parties of the computer age. And she says that first, sweetheart hired outside contractors for this makeover. But the company wasn't getting what it wanted. So, sweetheart turned to its own internal art department.
新十年即将来临。让我们用充满新鲜感的事物踢开90年代的大门，去迎接计算机时代的野餐和办公室派对。她说，起初，甜心公司曾聘请外部承包商来做这种大改造。但公司并没有得到想要的效果。于是，甜心公司转向了自己内部的美术部门。
And they made it a competition. And the winning design would become the company's brand new signature stock art. Whoa, okay, so how did that work? Like, were there kind of rules for the competition? Yes, so the specs were make it a one or two color design, something that was fairly clean, right? But also something that could be easily reprinted
他们举办了一场比赛。获胜的设计将成为公司全新的标志性常规艺术品。哇，好吧，那是怎么运作的呢？比如比赛有什么规则吗？是的，所以规格是：做成单色或双色设计，要相当简洁，对吧？但也必须能够轻松地重新印刷
without any mistakes, and it's got to fit on curved surfaces like plates and bowls and stuff. But, Guyna says that even inside of those parameters, she felt like sweetheart was willing to be a little bit adventurous. I thought immediately they're wanting to do something fresh and different.
而不会出现任何失误，而且它必须适合盘子和碗等曲面。不过，盖娜说，即使在这些参数之内，她觉得甜心公司也愿意进行一些冒险的尝试。我立刻想到他们想做一些新鲜和不同的东西。
They're wanting to kind of hit on a younger crowd of either vendors and or customers. They're wanting to kind of hit on a younger crowd of either vendors and or customers. People were wanting something a little live layer. So she pulled out some of her old college portfolios and she found some old designs that she could experiment with and she started tweaking them, playing with chalks and charcoals and pastels and paints. And so I just, I set there for hours and just made different swashes with the space of
他们希望吸引更年轻的供应商和/或客户群体。他们希望吸引更年轻的供应商和/或客户群体。人们想要一些更有生气的东西。于是她翻出了自己的一些大学作品集，找到了一些可以用来实验的旧设计，并开始对它们进行调整，用粉笔、木炭、蜡纸和颜料进行创作。所以我只是，我坐在那里几个小时，用木炭做出不同的笔触
charcoal until I got one that I liked. And then I got another type of charcoal, smaller piece, and experimented with the purple. Then I overlayed them and that's how it came together. Guyna's flying free hand sketched out those two zigzags, the skinny one in purple, and the big fat one in turquoise blue. Those were two of her favorite colors. Hmm. I mean, you know, the zigzag turquoise purple is like, that was everywhere that color. That was a real favorite of the moment for sure. At that time, it was peaking everywhere. Everybody had wild colored jogging suits and sneakers and things like that.
直到我得到一个满意的效果。然后我拿了另一种木炭，小一点的块状，用来试验紫色。接着我把它们叠印在一起，事情就这样成了。盖娜用自由奔放的手绘草图画出了那两个之字形：细细的紫色线条，和粗粗的绿松石蓝色线条。那也是她最喜欢的两种颜色。嗯。我的意思是，你知道，这种绿松石色和紫色的之字形就像是，那个颜色的随处可见。那绝对是当时真正的最爱。在那段时间里，它在各处都达到了顶峰。每个人都穿着色彩狂野的慢跑套装、运动鞋之类的东西。
I just thought, I want to pull this color. It's so different than anything that the corporation had printed before. And they were really, you know, saying they wanted to go in a new direction and drawing a lively or crowd or clientele. So I thought, well, if we're going to go all out, let's just go all out. I mean, there's a word to live by. If we're going to go all out, let's go all out. I mean, there's a word still live by. If we're gonna go all out, let's go all out. I mean, it sounds like she was encouraged internally to go all out, but I'm still actually kind of surprised now that I think about it.
我当时就想，我想提取这种颜色。它与这家公司以前印刷过的任何东西都如此不同。而且他们确实，你知道的，说过他们想朝着新的方向发展，吸引更有生气的人群或客户群。所以我想，既然我们要全力以赴，那就彻底放开手脚吧。我的意思是，这是一句生活的信条。如果我们打算全力以赴，那就全力以赴。我的意思是，这也是一句至今依然适用的座右铭。如果我们打算全力以赴，那就全力以赴。我的意思是，听起来她在内部受到了鼓励去全力以赴，但现在回想起来，我其实还是有点惊讶。
How bold it is. Yeah, it's true, and there was no guarantee that the company was gonna go for it. Everyone was allowed to submit up to four designs. And Gaina did that. She turned in her four sketches, crossed her fingers, and then the boss has come by her desk, and they say, we want to see you. And they just called me into the office and said, you know, this is what they've decided
它是多么的大胆。是的，确实如此，而且并不能保证公司一定会采用它。每个人最多可以提交四份设计。盖娜就是这么做的。她交出了她的四份草图，双手交叉祈祷，然后老板们来到她的办公桌前说，我们想见你。他们把我叫进办公室说，你知道，这就是他们决定
to go with. It's your design. It is. I was shocked. I was thrilled, but I was shocked. So Guyna was standing there in her boss's office. She's happy, she's shocked. And then they hit her with some more asks.
采用的设计。就是你的设计。真的是这样。我很震惊。我很兴奋，但也很震惊。所以盖娜站在她老板的办公室里。她很高兴，也很震惊。然后他们又向她提出了更多要求。
And then they're like, now we're kind of on a short time span here. We've got to get this into production. So we've got to come up with a name for it because they want to start advertising our new design. And I thought, how do I go about picking a name for a line of cut where I, you know, I'm right out of college. I didn't know what I was supposed to be doing. So now she's got to come up with a name for this thing. And that's really outside of her area of expertise. I mean, I mean, I think they gave her the opportunity to name it, but still,
然后他们说，现在我们的时间相当紧迫。我们必须把这个投入生产。所以我们必须给它起个名字，因为他们想开始宣传我们的新设计。我想，我怎么去为一条杯子生产线起名字呢？我才刚从大学毕业。我根本不知道自己该做什么。所以现在她得给这东西起个名字了。这真的超出了她的专业领域。我的意思是，我的意思是，我想他们给了她命名的机会，但依然，
that's so funny. So she does for the name exactly what she did for the design itself. She goes back to her old portfolios and she finds that design that she'd done for college. And the name of it had been Razi, R-A-Z-Z-I. And I said, well, what about like Jazzy or Jaz? And they were like, yeah, let's try that. Okay. Okay, so she comes up with both the design and the name. And this design is everywhere for decades at this point. Right, right.
这太有趣了。所以她为名字所做的事情，和她为设计本身所做的事情完全一样。她翻回自己的旧作品集，找到了她在大学时做过的一个设计。那个名字叫拉齐，R-A-Z-Z-I。我说，那叫“杰西”（Jazzy）或者“爵士”（Jazz）怎么样？他们说，行，那就试试这个。好的。好吧，她既想出了设计，又想出了名字。而这个设计在当时几十年里都无处不在。对，对。
Yeah. Did Guyna get anything for coming up with jazz? Honestly, not a whole lot. I mean, she says she got a $50 gift certificate. She got some swag with jazz printed on it and she got bragging rights. And that's it. Because she worked for sweetheart.
是的。盖娜因为想出“爵士”而得到了什么奖励吗？老实说，没有多少。我的意思是，她说她得到了一张50美元的礼品卡。她得到了一些印有“爵士”字样的周边纪念品，还获得了吹牛的资本。仅此而已。因为她在甜心公司工作。
So she says she signed papers that said that the design belonged to sweetheart. Yeah. And so Jazz gets copyrighted in the early 90s and it just takes off. And Gynast says she hasn't been able to escape the design since. I mean, I've seen like fake fingernails,
所以她说她签署了文件，表明该设计属于甜心公司。是的。所以“爵士”在90年代初获得了版权，然后它就彻底火了。盖娜说她从此再也无法逃脱这个设计。我的意思是，我看到过假指甲，
men's underwear. I mean, it's just anything fake fingernails, men's underwear. I mean, it's just anything you can imagine and a lot of things you can't imagine. I've seen it printed on. Ha, ha, ha, ha. Ha, ha, ha. Oh, you know, my son came home for Christmas two years ago. He had the sweatpants, the sweatshirt.
男士内衣。我的意思是，只要你能想象得到的任何东西，甚至很多你想象不到的东西。我都看到它被印在上面。哈哈哈哈。哈哈哈哈。哦，你知道的，我儿子两年前圣诞节回家时。他穿着运动裤、运动衫。
His girlfriend had the jazz mask. I think it's funny that her kids are kind of trolling her with her own design. Chris, this morning, that's hilarious. I mean, but she's totally right. You've seen it everywhere, even if you're just talking about cups and plates, you've seen it everywhere. And then it has totally transcended that. So she didn't get any real money for it.
他的女朋友戴着爵士图案的口罩。我觉得很有趣的是，她的孩子们竟然用她自己的设计来“捉弄”她。克里斯，今天早上，这太搞笑了。我的意思是，但她是完全对的。你到处都能看到它，即使你只是在讨论杯子和盘子，你也到处都能看到它。然后它完全超越了这些。所以她根本没有因此赚到真正的钱。
And she didn't get credit for it because it was a mystery until recently. What happened to Gynah after she came up with this design? So about a decade after the design comes out, Sweetheart gets bought by Solo Cup. Gynah's office in Springfield closes down, and she moves on to other jobs. She painted murals, she ran a landscape supply company with her husband, and today she's got a job at Hobby Lobby,
而且她也没有因此获得署名权，因为直到最近这还是个谜。盖娜在这个设计问世之后经历了什么？大约在这个设计问世十年后，甜心公司被独乐杯公司收购了。盖娜在斯普林菲尔德的办公室关闭了，她便转行做了其他工作。她画过壁画，和丈夫一起经营了一家园林绿化用品公司，而今天她在霍比洛比（Hobby Lobby）有一份工作，
but she's also making her own art. Well, I, it sounds odd, but I collect old cowboy boots and I make them into purses. I've had several ladies from, you know, all over the United States, like their husband might have passed. They send me his boots and I make them a purse out of them so they can carry it. That is a very specific form of art. So the jazz cup is still everywhere, the design is still everywhere. Do you have any idea why you think that is?
但她同时也还在创作自己的艺术作品。嗯，我，这听起来可能有点奇怪，我收集旧的牛仔靴，然后把它们改成钱包。我有好几个来自美国各地的女士，比如她们的丈夫可能去世了。她们把丈夫的靴子寄给我，我用这些靴子为她们做一个钱包，这样她们就可以随身携带了。这是一种非常独特的艺术形式。所以爵士杯依然无处不在，这个设计依然无处不在。你觉得这是为什么呢？
Yeah, well, I think at least part of it is that this design comes along just as the internet is becoming more and more a part of our lives. And so it's been that generation that really took that design and ran with it. Right, right. It's also like that generation got old enough to have nostalgia for things in the late 80s and early 90s. Yeah, they got old enough to go, oh, what about that sort of like fun and, you know, salient but also kind of little cheesy design from my youth
是的，嗯，我想至少部分原因是，这个设计恰好在互联网日益成为我们生活一部分的时候出现了。因此，正是那一代人真正接受了这个设计并将其发扬光大。对，对。这也像是那一代人长大了，对80年代末和90年代初的事物产生了怀旧之情。是的，他们长大了，会说：“哦，我当年青春时期那种有趣、显眼但又有点俗气的、现在因为种种原因我深爱的设计怎么样了，你知道的，就像是，”而且他们也觉得：“在我们找出究竟是谁创造了这件美妙作品之前，我们绝不罢休。”是的。因此，大约在七年前，当盖娜·伊基斯被证实是幕后推手时，该设计的狂热粉丝们兴奋极了。他们简直乐疯了。
that now I love for lots of reasons, you know, like, and they were also like, we will not rest until we find out who is responsible for this piece of beauty. Yes. And so when it came out about seven years ago that Guyna Iqas was responsible, adoring fans of the design, they were so thrilled. They lost their minds.
我现在出于很多原因而热爱它，你知道的，比如，他们也曾表示，在我们查出究竟是谁创造了这件美妙的艺术品之前，我们绝不罢休。是的。所以当大约七年前爆出是盖娜·伊卡斯（Guyna Iqas）负责创作时，设计狂热粉丝们兴奋极了。他们简直乐疯了。
And finally, it was so happy to finally put a name and a face to this flying purple and teal zigzag that so epitomized the late 80s and the early 90s. Which was all great, but then there was a problem. My name is Stephanie Miller, and I am the original designer of what became known as the jazz cup design. Oh no. Okay, so this woman's Stephanie Miller
最终，能够为这个完美诠释了80年代末和90年代初的飞扬紫色与青绿色之字形图案赋予一个名字和面孔，是多么令人高兴的一件事。这一切都很棒，但随后出现了一个问题。我叫斯蒂芬妮·米尔勒，我是后来被称为爵士杯设计的原设计者。哦，不。好吧，所以这个叫斯蒂芬妮·米尔勒的女人
and Gina are both claiming to be creators of the design jazz. Yep. Wow. So when the story came out seven years ago, naming Gina as the originator, Stephanie raised her hand on Twitter and Reddit and said, hold the phone. That's my design. Wow. Okay, so what is Stephanie's version of this story? Okay, so Stephanie lives in Sandesky, Ohio and I gave her a call and she told me, you know, she started off a lot like Gaina. She'd been making art since she was a kid. She went to college for graphic design and she got a job right after graduation at a company called Imperial Cup in Canton, Ohio. For years and years, Imperial had been using a design. It was basically just wheat printed on its cups and plates.
和盖娜都声称自己是爵士设计的创作者。是的。哇。所以当七年前命名盖娜为创始人的故事曝光后，斯蒂芬妮在推特和红迪网上举手表示，等一下。那是我的设计。哇。好吧，那么斯蒂芬妮对这个故事的说法是什么呢？好的，所以斯蒂芬妮住在俄亥俄州的桑达斯基，我给她打了个电话，她告诉我，你知道的，她的经历和盖娜非常相似。她从小就开始画画。她大学学习的是平面设计，毕业后立刻在俄亥俄州坎顿的一家名为帝国杯业的公司找到了一份工作。多年来，帝国杯业一直使用一种设计。那基本上只是印在杯子和盘子上的小麦图案。
It's wheat. Okay. Wheat. So, there's kind of nowhere to go but up, you know? And again, it's now the late 80s and Stephanie says Imperial was ready to switch things up. So she says she did a few different designs for them, including a paintbrushed thick blue zigzag
那是小麦。好吧。小麦。所以，除了往上走别无去路，对吧？而且再说一次，当时已经是80年代末了，斯蒂芬妮说帝国杯业已经准备好做出改变了。所以她说她为他们做了几个不同的设计，包括一个用画笔画的粗蓝色之字形，
with a thinner purple zigzag brushed over top of it. She called her design brush strokes. Imperial cup picked that design, put it on their products, and brush strokes was out in the world. And then, along the holds, and brush strokes was out in the world. And then, lo and behold, a design that was almost identical from sweetheart came out. But basically, the only difference between the designs were the materials used to make it.
上面还刷有一条较细的紫色之字形。她把她的设计命名为“画笔痕迹”。帝国杯业选中了这个设计，将其印在产品上，“画笔痕迹”就这样问世了。然后，就在这时，“画笔痕迹”问世了。紧接着，意想不到的事情发生了，甜心公司推出了一款几乎一模一样的设计。但基本上，这两种设计唯一的区别在于制作时所使用的材料。
I did paint brush strokes, and it looks like she had used charcoal, but it was exactly the same. So Stephanie's hypothesis is that a salesman at Sweetheart saw an Imperial Cup with her design on it and liked it. They took the cup over to Guinas desk, put it down in front of her and said, this is great. Make a version of this for us. And according to Stephanie's version of events, Sweetheart, who would have stolen the design from Imperial, then sent Imperial
我用的是画笔，而她看起来像是用了木炭，但它们完全一样。所以斯蒂芬妮的假设是，甜心公司的某个销售人员在帝国杯业的一个杯子上看到了她的设计，并且很喜欢。他们把这个杯子拿到了盖娜的办公桌前，放在她面前说，这太棒了。给我们也做一个这样的版本。根据斯蒂芬妮的说法，本应从帝国杯业盗取设计的甜心公司，随后向帝国杯业发送了一封
a cease and desist letter. Like, stop making the design, we just stole from you, or we're gonna sue. Okay, I think I'm following this. So, if sweetheart sent Imperial a cease and desist letter, is there proof of that? Like, is that show up anywhere? No. Stephanie, so far far hasn't produced any proof. And as for Guyna, you know, Sweetheart still has the copyright on jazz. And another company called Dart Container, that's the company that now owns Sweetheart, they wrote me to say this.
停止侵权警告函。就像是，停止制作我们刚刚从你那里偷来的设计，否则我们要起诉了。好吧，我想我听懂了。所以，如果甜心公司向帝国杯业发送了停止侵权警告函，有证据吗？这在什么地方显示出来过吗？没有。到目前为止，斯蒂芬妮还没有出示任何证据。至于盖娜，你知道的，甜心公司仍然拥有爵士的版权。而另一家名为Dart Container的公司——也就是现在拥有甜心公司的公司——他们写信给我这样说道：
The jazz design was originally created in the late 1980s by Gaina Iqis, a sweetheart company employee, as part of an internal design contest for a new stock image. She chose her favorite color turquoise and purple since it went so well with turquoise. So it seems pretty settled at at this point unless something else comes out. Exactly. That's exactly right. I mean, so I listened to you talking to Gaina and she seemed like she's laughing and enjoying this and, you know, and doesn't seem particularly put out that she didn't make a lot of money for her med or, you know, it kind of seems to enjoy it being seen on, you know, men's box of shorts and things like that. Did you get a sense from her that this was anything but a good memory for her?
爵士设计最初是由甜心公司的员工盖娜·伊基斯在20世纪80年代末作为新常规图像内部设计比赛的一部分创作的。她选择了自己最喜欢的颜色——青绿色和紫色，因为它们与青绿色搭配得非常好。所以目前看来这件事已经尘埃落定了，除非有其他情况出现。完全正确。绝对是这样。我的意思是，我听了你和盖娜的谈话，她似乎在笑着享受这一切，你知道的，而且似乎并没有因为没有靠这个设计赚到大钱而感到特别不快，或者说，你知道的，她似乎挺享受看到它出现在男士短裤盒之类的东西上。你从她身上感觉到这不仅仅是一段美好的回忆吗？
Oh my God. What you're hearing is exactly what our one-hour phone call was like. She just seemed so proud of what she'd done and also amused by the fact that it is still getting a lot of attention that it has sort of found the second life in popular culture. I think that it also just means something to her that the perfection of the design is borne out by the fact that other people have picked it up and given it so much love and props, like as a graphic designer, she seems pretty thrilled just by that. And there is also just something really elegant and beautiful in a certain way,
哦天哪。你现在听到的正是我们那一小时电话采访的真实写照。她看起来为自己所做的事感到无比骄傲，同时也对它依然受到很多关注、在流行文化中焕发第二春感到十分开心。我想，其他人也挑选了她的设计并给予了如此多的喜爱和支持，这证明了该设计的完美性，这对她来说也意义重大。作为一个平面设计师，她似乎仅仅因为这一点就感到相当兴奋。而且某种程度上，其中也确实存在着一种真正优雅和美丽的东西，
about the way she captures a moment. That's what's crazy is that it really is of the moment that design really does center you in 1990. But it also became timeless because it was so specific, which is a thing I kind of love about a certain type of design is that the the soul of it is its specificity and and therefore it is universal and that's great. Yeah, you nailed it. Well, thank you, Chris, for I love this story. This is so much fun.
关于她捕捉时代瞬间的方式。最疯狂的是，这个设计确实极具时代感，它真的能把你带回到1990年的情境中。但它同时也变得永恒了，因为它如此具体，这也是我某种程度上喜欢特定类型设计的一点，那就是它的灵魂就在于它的具体性，因此它也是普遍的，这太棒了。是的，你抓得太准了。好的，谢谢你，克里斯，我很喜欢这个故事。这太有趣了。
Thanks, Roman. 99% Invisible was produced this week by its Laney Hall, Kurt Colestead and Christopher Johnson, mixed in tech production by Amidig Anatra, music-buyer director of sound, Swan Rial. The rest of the team is Vivian Le, Emmett Fitzgerald, Lashma Don, Chris Barouba, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatskuh, and me Roman Mars. We are part of the Citroen Series XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars
谢谢你，罗曼。《99%隐形》本周由莱妮·霍尔、库尔特·科尔斯特德和克里斯托夫·约翰逊制作，由阿米迪格·安娜特拉负责混音与技术制作，音乐总监兼声音总监是斯旺·里尔。团队的其他成员包括维维安·勒、埃姆杰·菲茨杰拉德、拉什玛·唐、克里斯·巴鲁巴、乔·罗森伯格、索菲亚·克拉茨库赫，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是SiriusXM播客大家庭的一员，总部目前位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区上城潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上@我 @Roman Mars
and the show at 99PI orc. Well, on Instagram and Reddit too. You can find links to other n-p-i-dot-org. Duh, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
也可以@节目 @99PI org。在Instagram和红迪网上也能找到我们。你可以在...找到链接。呃，咚，咚，咚，咚...本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。